i'm genuinely excited to welcome uh this
guest into
uh our our midst for the very first time
hopefully the first of many times
because he is to say a highly touted
prospect in this year's nfl draft is an
understatement bucky brooks
my colleague at nfl network the nfl
media group
whose uh talent evaluation skills are
second to none
calls this guy this tight end
this tremendous football player a
gold jacket talent
and yet he won't be the first overall
pick in this draft because he's not a
quarterback
from the university of florida kyle
pitts here in the rich eisen show how
are you kyle
i'm doing good thank you guys for the
opportunity thank you for
making this phone call what has life
like
been like for you last few weeks kyle
pitts
uh life's been i would say slowed down
now that we're you know i'm not
preparing for the combine anymore in
pro day so just getting back to getting
in football shape so
i took a couple days off now i'm you
know back in full stride
getting getting ready uh back running on
the field you know
heavier weights you know position work
so just getting back to
you know the regular way is not you know
preparing for a showcase i guess you
would say so are you saying that guy who
ran a four forward his pro day was not
in shape
technically kyle did i just overhear
that did i just hear that from you i
would say
i would say i was in combine shape but
you know football shape is different you
have to run some pads on you run for
long periods of time you always run
40 40 yards in a straight line so that's
something that was i was in shape for
that you know now i have to transition
to the
the other type of you know in shape like
i should say when you hear
uh that you are considered by some
and by some i think you could say by
many uh a gold jacket
talent what do you think of when you
hear that
kyle pitts that's amazing
you know that's obviously everyone's end
goal before the super bowl but to be
able to
be in the mentions of you know someone
thinking i could be i have that
opportunity to have my face and you know
in canton ohio and the
hall of fame uh hallway is
is what every kid dreams for and you
know
if i do it you know god bless me to get
to that and get that gold jacket that's
you know
i feel like that's the highest of the
high you know once you get into the
league
you always want to get rookie to your
pro bowl super bowl but
to be hall of fame that's something no
one could take from me so that's
something every i feel like football
players goal is to reach and
hopefully i'll reach it one day who will
uh a team be getting if they draft kyle
pitts
kyle pitts tell me what would a team be
getting if they draft you
a team will be getting a great young man
to start off with
off the field and on the field i would
say
just a hard worker someone who's about
his business i'm professional about my
business you know i like to take care of
my business first football is my life
it's my job
you know now that i'm out of college i
don't have to worry about academics so
this is
you know what i do this is what i get
paid for so
everything is devoted to this and you
know when the day is over is when i kick
my feet up you know
relax but while i have to handle my
business that's what i do
well i mean the number of of of lists
that i see
and they a lot of them cross my path you
know i will be
definitely sitting on nfl network when i
hear your name be mentioned by
commissioner roger goodell and we'll be
talking about you with your new team
live on nfl network when that happens in
a few
thursdays so i've i've been around the
block a few times when i see
in many ways a consensus this kid is the
number one
prospect in the draft i normally think
that they're going to be
drafted first overall but all i keep
hearing is yeah but he's a tight end
what do you think of when you hear that
kyle pitts
i kind of know that's how it is no i'm
not a quarterback quarterbacks usually
are
last way longer than titans but nowadays
you know you kind of see titans lasting
long but
uh to even be considered you know
possibly the number one pick i mean i'm
sorry i'm not gonna pick number one
draft prospect is something special
because
i i put a lot of hard work into this and
you know
being it being noticed something that
you know heartwarming but at the same
time it's a lot of work that was done in
the dark but
uh when the day comes you know i feel
like
i am a tight end at the end of the day
but i feel like i'm the best titan so
uh over the years i'm going to prove
that and you know make sure that
i know i'll never have a chance to never
pick but
in my eyes being the first pass catcher
first off
you know after the quarterback that's
something that's important to me
do you think jacksonville should take
you kyle
i don't know i don't have an answer for
sure you do the answer is yes
kyle pitts you could say yeah
jacksonville should take you you know
what i mean i mean i saw i definitely
think they should take me but you know i
can't control what happens on draft of
course you can't so but you can
definitely control
i guess who you talk to in a way i mean
you might want to reach out to others
but
the way it works is teams reach out to
you to interview
um how many teams have you interviewed
with on zoom
kyle uh i don't
i would say around i haven't met with
every team okay i've met with most teams
and uh i've uh just they've gone through
my agent to show their meetings but i
haven't met all thirsty teams
okay but you have done zoom interviews
right with them or
have you ever okay you have um let's
let's uh let's just if you don't mind
take a couple boxes
um i know this is kind of like fight
club but it doesn't matter everyone will
find out anyway at some point
um did one has one team that's spoken to
you have a star on the side of their
helmet kyle pitts
[Laughter]
yes i have spoken to the cowboys okay
you have have you spoken to jerry jones
himself
yes sir okay um what can you share about
that conversation because apparently
he he was quote unquote i don't know if
you heard the report infatuated
with and by you kyle have you heard that
report
uh i actually i'd rather not read the
press clipping okay
i feel like you know like coach saban
says rap but so
you know until the day comes i won't you
know worry about that
uh someone did call me and tell me about
that and this you know it's kind of a
honor for him to say that and you know
dallas was a great team
if i could ever have the opportunity to
play for would be a great you know thing
but you but you grew up you grew up in
philadelphia right kyle
you're you're you're yeah yeah that
that's kind of i would say the oxymoron
and uh me growing up the eagles saying
they didn't have to
have the opportunity to play for the
cowboys so that'd be a hard time getting
some of my family jerseys because they
died
so that'd be something funny so what did
uh what happened in the pitts household
when the eagles traded out of six
kyle what happened in that household
when that happened the other day
actually nothing you know they know
they're not you know
heavily into it to the point where it's
like we want you playing for the eagles
you know
they just wanna you know they're just
enjoying the process like myself so
okay just seeing where all the chips
fall and if i did
if if they didn't have trade back then i
got the opportunity to play for the
eagles would have been a great thing but
you know what we're not stressing about
it we just you know
like i said that the chips fall with it
of course because you can't control it
and your family only wants
the best for you but you do realize that
if they
they live in philadelphia your your
family still they live there
still sir okay they're the only ones in
philadelphia who felt that way when the
eagles
fell out of the sick spot you realize
that right that
they're the only
[Music]
oh my gosh have the 49ers reached out to
you have you chatted with them
uh i talked to them once or twice it
wasn't that much but
okay yeah what about the falcons have
you spoken to them
yes sir okay we're at the top of the
draft this is
it so um where do you think you're gonna
wind up kyle i know that's a tough
question to ask a prospect who you're
excited to go wherever you want to go
and you're very excited
what are you thinking right now in your
head kyle pitts
just a couple weeks before the draft uh
i i wish i could give you an straight
answer but because i feel like it's
another trade up or trade down or
something to get moved around on the
draft a lot of weird things happening
there
uh so i don't really have any
expectations to go anywhere but i do
hope to
you know my my intercept goal is like to
go top six or
top ten that's something that you know i
want to do jonathan fowler went
five i think out of florida and then the
highest pick out of philly ever was
14 sharif floyd i think so that i want
to top those numbers and
and set the set of new standards yeah
i mean because that you know so you
could look at emmett smith next time and
say you
you you sliced it in half or something
like that or we don't talk to emmett
that way
right out of florida
i just love it kyle i just love dreams
coming true i love dreams coming true
and what has happened to you in the last
few weeks
you know obviously we saw what was going
on with you this year
been in winning the mackey award and
with 12 touchdowns unanimous
all-american the blossoming that took
place for you on this campus but over
the last two
three months there are fan bases all
over the nfl who feel that you could
take them
to the promised land what do you tell
fans that are saying
i want my team to draft kyle pitts what
do you say to all these people who are
reading into every single word that you
say
hoping that you wear the uniform of that
team
oh i'll just say i appreciate all all
the love and support
but at the same time people that you
know you have all the love it's just my
love as it is hate so
just keep it keep the same energy and if
i do you know whatever team i get picked
i'm going to give my all you know every
day you know even when it's not on
television and just trying to
provide a extra boost for the offense
that i'm that i'm in
what's your plan for draft night
i'm going to the draft okay i'll be in
cleveland
who's with you i'll be in the tennis my
family who's who's coming with you
kyle can you walk me through who's going
to be with you
mom dad sister girlfriend my trainer
coach mullen and uh my tight end coach
coach uh
larry scott that's so exciting for you
have you got your
suit picked out kyle pitts have you got
your draft
situation picked out i yes sir i do
okay do you want to give a shout out you
want to give a shout out here because i
know you say you're all about business
this is part of business
it is part of business what are you gone
yeah i want to shout out rob
redman okay uh he he's the god of
atlanta
uh i don't have a different damn sign
but okay because i think it's
it's uh ryde redman okay he's just like
you know
a stylist and he does a lot of suits for
guys okay
so do we have a special lining is it uh
gator lining what
do we have anything that's in i can't
tell you the secret
someone's gonna try and take it okay
let's not do that
but um do the fact that you are
your your clothier your outfitter is in
atlanta should we
should we take that to mean that you're
you've got atlanta on your mind
then kyle i wouldn't go that far
because i met him and he still happened
to be in atlanta
and then maybe you might just happen to
be in atlanta anyway so we could put it
all together
hey kyle hopefully this is the first of
many times you appear on the show
congratulations with about all the
accolades you're coming your way
you know um i i love hearing how you
you're you're not really paying
attention what people are saying on
twitter all the sorts of
you know tugs at your at your figurative
sleeve
for attention and maybe coming at you
seems like you've got a really great um
team around you
congratulations on all of this and let's
chat after you get let's chat after you
get drafted
by the dallas cowboys
[Laughter]
we'll see how it goes kyle thanks for
the call appreciate it
you bet thank you i appreciate it that
is kyle pitts
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here